yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
Pixar's seventeenth feature film finding
dory is stuffed to the gills with Easter
eggs the usual suspects are all in there
a 1 1 3 the Pizza Planet truck the luxo
ball previous and upcoming Pixar movies
as well as Star Wars Disney and other
classic movie references so in this
video I'm going to look at all the
Easter eggs references and cameos are
found in the movie ok just before I
weighed in I've got a really special the
art of finding Dory book to give away
from my friends at Abraham's & Chronicle
it's packed with beautiful concept art
sketches and information that give a
glimpse into the making of the movie for
a chance to win all you have to do is
subscribe and leave a comment on this
video about your favorite Easter Egg
already finding Dory or let me know
about one I missed and of course there
are spoilers ahead so if you're not
ready for that check out my non-spoiler
review the movie right here there are
some nice Pixar Easter eggs hidden in
the quarantine lab stuck to the wall
behind the fish tank is a picture of
Darla the fish killing niece of dentist
P Sherman in Finding Nemo the lonely
volcano from the short film lava which
played before inside out also appears on
a fridge magnet to the right of the
scene and is an Easter Egg for Piper the
beautiful pixar short which played
before finding dory the cute Sam Piper
hatchling gets a visual shout-out in a
poster behind Hank that he scoops Dory
out of the fish tank with the coffee jug
Pixar's movie wall-e gets a well-hidden
reference in the scene where Hank is
about to drop Dory into the huge fish
tank in the aquarium
there's a calendar with wall-e written
on it in the background of that scene
the turtle crush of course appears again
in finding Dory helping Marlin Nemo and
Dory get to Morro Bay but a model of him
also hangs from the ceiling in the
aquarium at the marine life Institute
a113 appears twice in finding Dory the
first time it flashes on and off the
screen very quickly on the back flippers
of sea lions fluke and rudder which
attacked a 1 and 13 by the way though
sea lions are voiced by Idris Elba and
Dominic West who starred in the wire
together the second time a 1 1 3 appears
is much easier to spot as it's on the
license plate of the truck transporting
Hank Marlin a Nemo to Cleveland the
license plate reads cowl a113 the a
one three East Egg has appeared in every
single Pixar movie to date and is in a
march to the classroom at the California
Institute of the Arts and where the
likes of Pixar's John Lasseter finding
dory director Andrew Stanton studied
there's a really sneaky luxo ball Easter
egg which you can spot very briefly in
the center of the steering wheel as Hank
is driving off with a transport truck
and interestingly the way it appears
also looks rather like Captain America's
shield as well
the luxo ball goes back to Pixar's very
first animation a short film called luxo
jr. which features both the luxo ball
and to debt lamps one of which appears
in Pixar's logo director Andrew Stanton
has confirmed that the Pizza Planet
truck appears early in the movie and
recently when I spoke with the movie's
director of photography in McKibben he
told me it's around the sequence that
features what he called the movie's
monster and actually that means it's
hidden among the objects scattered in
the shipping lanes before dory Marlin a
Nemo meet the giant squid and in the
highway scene were Hank commandeered a
truck there are also glimpses of various
cars on the road which look quite a bit
like the Pizza Planet truck - in the
Gibbon also told me that there's an
easter egg - Pixar's next movie Cars 3
close to where we see the luxo ball in
the movie so look out for that there's
another sneaky Easter egg on one of the
pipes at the marine life Institute which
says sea water supply tl 59 on it that
phrase actually appears on a pipe above
the line for the submarine voyage
attraction at Disneyland with tl
standing for Tomorrowland and 59 being
the year the ride was opened and
interestingly enough that attraction was
actually repurposed in 2007 with a
Finding Nemo theme the number-3 won 8-1
on the tag that Dory gets at the marine
life Institute is a triple Star Wars and
Pixar Easter Egg the stormtrooper
fn-2187 z' and that stormtrooper just
happens to be played by regular Pixar
composer Michael Giacchino who's also
composed the music for many of JJ Abrams
other productions and on top of that is
stormtrooper number three one eight one
can be rearranged as one one three eight
making is a hidden nod
George Lucas's 1971 film thx 1-1 3-8 the
touch pool scene at the aquarium had a
horror movie feel about it with a fish
cowering in fear where the children's
hands stop plunging into the water and
it's actually reminiscent of two moments
in the Toy Story movies there's a time
the children run rampage with woody and
his friends in the playroom in Toy Story
3 and the children's hands smashing into
the touch pool are also evocative of the
giant claw game that Sid plays in the
original Toy Story movie Marlins lines
at crossing the ocean is the kind of
thing you should only do once is a meta
reference to the filmmakers decision to
keep the journey from the coral reef to
California just one short scene because
they didn't want finding Dory to be
another road movie like Finding Nemo and
when Hank fills a touch pool with ink
and then apologizes it's a callback to
how the baby squid and Finding Nemo inks
itself when one of his friends pretends
to push him off the drop off there's
also a nod to the moment where Dory
calls the baby jellyfish squishy and
Finding Nemo when she's searching for a
parents in the kelp forest and says she
likes sand because sand is squishy Pixar
itself also gets an Easter Egg in the
form of the numbers 12 hundreds and 86
both of which appear on the side of the
speedboat that picks up Dory the numbers
are a reference to Pixar's address at
twelve-hundred Park Avenue Emeryville
and to the year that Pixar was founded
1986
this needs VW beetle Herbie which is
featured in a number of movies over the
years looks like it may have sadly ended
up rusting on the bottom of the ocean
floor and finding Dory a funny moment in
the film occurs when Dory swims to the
surface near the marine life Institute
and says hello and she hears a voice
respond hello I'm Sigourney Weaver
Dorian has a hilarious discussion with
the automated voice of Sigourney Weaver
playing over the tannoy at the Institute
this is a clever nod to Weaver's role as
the voice as a ship's computer in
Pixar's wall-e and there's also a really
neat reference to one of Weaver's most
iconic movies aliens and the scene where
Bailey sees what he thinks is Dori
getting eaten alive by another huge fish
in the pipes the way Bailey ceases
happened using his echolocation is an
homage to the scene from alien where the
character Dallas gets taken by the alien
while stuck in a ventilation
shaft the pipe sequence may also be one
of the two references the filmmakers
have said they made to die hard in
finding dory after they saw a spoof of
how all the Pixar movies are connected
to the die hard movie franchise and the
second die hard reference comes up when
Dory is looking for Hank in the touch
pool the other fish shout out hands
hands to warn her the kids are coming
but Dory misunderstands implies no not
hums I'm looking for Hank Hans Gruber is
of course the villain from the first die
hard movie after the movies credits have
rolled the tank gang from Finding Nemo
makes their return it's a funny moment
when Nemo's old friends roll up in front
of the rock where sea lions rudder and
fluke are sleeping the gang got all
still in the plastic bags they were in
last time we saw them but everyone's bag
has turned green with algae except for
Jack's it's a phone call back to the
first movie when the tank gang
deliberately made their fish tank go
green by sabotaging their water filter
and had to stop Jack's natural
inclination to clean the tank through a
bunch of cool cameos in finding dory
including Pixar's lucky charm John
Ratzenberger who plays the husband crab
bill who you see cutting grass while
dory asked his wife for directions to
the quarantine lab Alexander Gould who
voiced Nero in the original film 13
years ago cam uses the voice of the
truck driver passenger Bill Hader who is
a voice of fear and inside out it plays
the voice of Stan the husband fish who
appears at the beginning of the movie
when baby dory is lost and looking for a
family the fact haters character and
Doria talking about short-term memory
loss seems nicely appropriate not only
for dory situation here but also because
of Haider's rollin inside out which was
all about memory by the way Haider's
wife fish is voiced by his SNL co-star
Kate McKinnon director Andrew Stanton is
back voicing crush the sea turtle again
but he also lends his voice to the clam
that Marlon and Nemo encounter when they
escape from the fish tank at the gift
shop and is also an heir of Little Shop
of Horrors bloodthirsty flytrap like
plant in the look of the rather
talkative clam other Pixar crew carrying
include film editor Torben Shan Bullock
as the sea line Gerald curacy Gerald is
the same name as a pelican who chokes on
Marlin and Dory in Finding Nemo and both
Gerald's have a similar coming
function as the bus of jokes and
co-director Angus macLane is the sunfish
Charlie back and forth he was also in
Finding Nemo so were there any cool
Easter eggs already as you spotted that
I missed and who was your favorite new
character in finding dory I'd love to
know in the comments below and don't
forget to subscribe and comment for your
chance to win the stunning the art of
finding dory hardback book for bonus
ways to enter the giveaway check out the
gleam link in the video description
below if you're a Pixar fan I'll have
more finding Dory videos soon including
a video on some amazing deleted scenes
and concepts from the movie and you can
also check out more of my Easter egg
videos but inside out and the good
dinosaur in my Pixar playlist below
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers